Well, well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Okay.
Tick Tock.
Nice.
You got to have a career
that was on a Tuesday.
I'd be like,
Oh,
I'm a bad my day because I make crazy
as videos told me about my hair.
Fucking
the life.
You'll dig, dig, dig,
dig,
dig in a wrong
sound.
Speaks down here. Damn. When somebody's
comment under one of my video,
hi.
No waterfall that I am blessed.
You know what I mean? Wow.
So good. Yeah. So good.
Uh, what'd you want to
turn my shit up? Okay.
Uh, is that you? Sorry.
Here we go. You good?
You want to fuck with my mind?
I want to,
she's Vietnamese, right? I Dunno,
it sounds Vietnamese. No. Yeah,
there's a new master of accent.
Everybody.
I'm the Max Master of Asian Erickson's.
Cause I did a Chinese.
Remember that time? Yeah,
I remember that. Masters.
Uh, this is, uh, submitted by soul 45.
I like it. Thanks. So 45
try to be better about
naming the submission people. It's
tough to stay on top. All right,
so next week. Well, first of all,
huge thank you to everybody that came
out to the shows and a sperm can.
They were really fun. Thank you guys very
much. I'm going to Saks on bill Florida.
Um,
that's okay.
It's not very good sax on Jackson Dicks.
There you go. That's better. I'm
going to Jackson. Dick's, Florida.
That's much better.
The comedy zone
in Jacksonville. Janet
Jackson next week, fifth,
sixth and 7th of May. Um,
and then sewer, Jewish,
New York, May 20th and
21st. It's only four shows.
We're very next week actually for
his jeans. Uh, is in Lajolla. Yeah,
you're in the [inaudible] man.
Diego and Diego doing the comedy,
the store comedy start.
And then in June I'm in per vine.
Kyla, California. That's good. I
should I or you're writing your ride
at the Improv there? Irvine
Spectrum Mall. That's the ninth,
10th and 11th. And then
Nashville. Nashville. Good.
Yeah. Crack. Good cash
bill. Ashville. Asheville.
Oh. Even better than
Nashville. Tennessee. June,
1617 and 18 feet a minute.
That's my birthday. June 18
yeah. Which number is it?
The student layers birthday.
What's your birthday? Is it
40? I don't look at
though. People are like,
what did you look great?
You look amazing.
And then I'm going to west
ball sack New York. Uh,
I don't know what the real place. West
Nyack. Oh, night. Yeah. White Ball sack.
Then west and there was not sac west.
Not sack.
Yeah, you keep the end. The end.
So you got to give the end of that.
That's really important.
That's June 23rd through 25th I've
never been to that club. Really Fun.
Really big club. Beautiful Club.
They really did a great job.
The kids are gonna like the
way you look at. Oh yeah,
that's that man.
So we plugged mine to colony star.
May 27th 28th in Lajolla also come see me.
I'm at the comedy store here in Hollywood.
Most Saturdays of the 7:30 PM show.
Come see me. Lineups are killer. I
just doesn't show this. Last Saturday.
Mark Marin was there. Judd Apatow
towel. Little indie filmmaker. Yeah.
Dane Cook was doing spots. The store
is on fire right now. Go. Go to it.
There you go. That's what's up.
Oh, locally, I will be at the, uh,
Improv this week. Right.
You're doing Friday night,
late late show,
Friday around.
Come see you for your bud
halls. Just Rick. Good.
So yeah. Thank you guys. Um, all my shows,
Thomson [inaudible] Dot com get
your tickets, get your life.
Are you all set then Jean?
I'm ready to party.
Um,
also of course we went to
knowledge our producer acknowledge,
oh,
I thought you said knowledge like rapper,
say Blue Band is here.
Oh,
look at you. You got your own drive.
Yeah. Maybe we'll show his face one day.
Who knows? Maybe you'll do
a mother fucker. Yo. So,
um,
lots intense Mamsen intense drop.
You okay with that blue man? I blew
it quite yet. Or is he loves it.
One thing too guys,
if you've done it before,
thank you for using our Amazon banner, but
if you're shopping on Amazon, I please,
please beg you, use your mom's
house, podcast dot coms portal.
Go to the banner at the
bottom of our homepage.
Click on it and do your shopping is
normally would, it's a huge help for us.
It actually, you know, it helps,
it helps us be able to,
um,
do a lot of things we do on this show.
It,
it helps contribute to the fact
that we have a full time producer,
producer, director days, a
choreographer, but all that. Yeah,
it definitely helps. Thank you
guys. Um, you ready James? Yeah,
we got so much to go over.
It's kind of ridiculous.
I actually didn't even bookmark
any of use as the opening clip.
Um, I dunno. What should we go for
the Oh yeah, that's pretty amazing. Okay.
Okay, here we go. Let me
see if I can, I totally,
every justice voice makes me laugh.
I know what I press control
away. Commander. Who's funnier?
The Joey Diaz cause you space bar. You got
double click it to open up. God dammit.
This is good for the show.
Okay.
Watching an 80 year old,
I hear Linkedin is helpful.
How do I log in
man
areas again.
So what do I do,
Amanda? Okay, here we go. This guy,
let's get this show started.
I told me everyday I'm gonna tell you who
harasses me that I could press charges.
No Lincoln Lincoln then
harasses me every fucking day.
The social network,
it's a bunch of bums and I'm working
so stop hitting me up on linkedin.
I'm not even opening up that account.
I don't fuck with Lincoln
professionals. You're a fucking moron.
You ain't no fucking professional.
Don't bring it
to your mom's 11
Christina
dammit. That is so fucking
funny. Linkedin is helpful.
Lincoln Lincoln, Lincoln
done. I won't fuck with
you know I've heard that
Joey and I overlap. We don't
like text messages either.
Oh my God. Set. Right.
He told me one time,
I'm going to break your fingers
if you send me another text.
Dunkin is,
I'll stab your
link.
Get in like then that and didn't,
didn't he say he couldn't say Kainoa quit.
He said to me on a flight,
we got like first class bullshit meal.
Give you fucking quit now.
Now Joey came on our show
back when your mom's house.
We were filming in our house in
Silver Lake, all old schools.
Before I really knew him.
I just,
I just met the guy and he was telling the
story about taking a shit on a tree in
his backyard. Do you remember that?
Oh my God. His own house. He said,
think things on that episode.
We can make songs.
I told me every day
I could press charges. Lincoln, Lincoln,
harasses me every fuck Lincoln.
Did
you press charges against
the social network?
It's a bunch of bums, so stop hitting
me up on linkedin. I'm not even opening
professionals.
You're a fucking moron.
Bunch of bumps as the best man.
Uncle Joey.
That is just too much.
I laugh.
I was had a fucking aneurism when I
saw that the other day. I love that.
None of them correct them either.
No, you don't crack Joey Diaz.
I'm the best part is a joy. He asked me
to do his podcast when I was pregnant.
Yeah.
And I was like,
I don't want to inhale all that
second hand weed smoke. You know,
I had to be, I couldn't tell
him why, but I was like,
I don't think I should do your show. Oh
really? Oh, I want a contact high. Right,
right, right. And I was pregnant.
And it's kind of inevitable
when you're working with
Joey. Coco Diaz. Yeah. No, no.
You're going to get high. You're going
to get hired in the room. Shake his hand.
That's like God at all.
And you were all Prager's so you
kind of knew the answer. Yeah,
sure. Linkedin? No. Where's
the come to where the com is?
Yeah.
It's all up inside of you.
God.
Yeah. Wow. You're fired up today.
And Gray whisker. I'm so, I know I
got so many grand whiskers. Yeah.
And in your hair to this morning,
I noticed you got a lot more a fashion
combing my hair. Salt and common Mary.
Yeah. A lot of combing your
hair. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Hey.
So do you like my jacket? I
do. Like you're dragging today.
It's funny cause when I bought
this jacket, yeah, you were like,
you look like macgyver.
It's, it's, you know,
it's interesting is
that now that I go back,
does this is the third jacket
that you've mocked me for? Well,
no one jacket you put on. I
go, I hate that. Hate it. Yeah,
I remember that jacket. Right. I hated
that track. Yeah, I know. Thank you.
I and I threw it away promptly cause I
don't want you to have to hate what I'm
wearing. Right. But I also use,
you told me that you really appreciated
me saying how I felt about it.
Right. Because you said that I always am
like, hey, cool. Here's the thing though.
This macgyver jacket. Yeah. Actually
I think looks really good on,
I really think is cool on
the video. Yeah. I like,
it covers up my fatness and
everything and it's a nice color.
What do I liked the jacket.
Okay,
well you didn't before you told me
never to wear this. You're like stupid.
Are May. You did. You're so fucking
crazy. What are you talking?
I didn't say don't wear that.
You look stupid like that,
but you were like at the a, you were
like, you just want, you went plan. Uh,
it looks like macgyver and then I just
stopped wearing it for like a year.
I don't remember that at all. I don't
remember that at all. What happened? Okay.
I mean your version of Shit. I think
it happens in your head and you see it.
You and what are you talking about?
You talked to it just because you
don't remember it. I'm crazy. Well,
I remember fighting conversation we had
the other day that you just completely
spun around which conversation.
Yeah. Okay. Which conversation?
I'll tell you what's conversation.
This fucking conversation right here.
Yes sir.
I'm going to start this shit off.
Straight telling all this land
with my name is going on there.
Let's go stop playing with my fucking
name. That's good. We'll do it on camera.
That plan with my name and I go right.
Let me go with my name. Come up respected.
Go not playing with my fucking name. Oh,
drill. Y'All stop playing
with my name. Angle said no.
So
that was intense. And when I
told you about that, right?
Yes sir. I'm going to start this shit. I'm
here. What's happening? I'm all good, but
I want to see,
so this is a,
for people listening,
obviously we haven't done a good job
of introducing what they're listening.
By the way,
if you're just listening to the show,
you're really missing out because we're
on youtube now, full episodes and you can
see the clips that you're hearing. Talk
about a huge improvement in your life.
So subscribe to us on Youtube.
Okay.
Slash your mom's house podcast,
right?
youtube.com/podcast subscribe because
all we also have behind the scenes.
Yeah,
no that was it.
I got a good idea. So tell, tell
everybody what they're listening to.
So this is the bird man.
No,
I saw this on Instagram cause I think
Merlin Wayne's had posted it and I just
saw some guy getting all pissed and
I saw it and I like filed it away.
And then you brought it up and I was like,
who?
Because I didn't know that guy's name was
bird man. And then you're like Birdman.
And I'm like,
oh I don't know who that is.
And then I later her put the
two things together in my head.
But you're accusing me of lying and
you're calling me crazy. Cause I,
we had a phone call over the weekend,
I was in sperm can and I'm
talking to you and I explained,
explained to you in detail about this.
And then when we sat down here and you go,
do you have the Birdman clip? And I go,
yeah, of course. And you go, oh yeah, like
I told you about that. And I was like,
what are you talking
about? He goes, I told you.
They say I told you about that. I
did. Oh, I was joking. I know, I know.
I knew I didn't break the news to you.
I just had seen it as what I said.
That's what I meant. Rather, I was
familiar with the bird man's work. Okay.
Pick on my name. But
he's, he's crazy, ugly cry
dude. He's so mad at them. So
let's go over for what's going on.
So Birdman,
for those of you that don't know,
he is a hip hop mogul.
Like one of the ogs from the 90s
he started cash money records.
He had that,
you know,
that whole wave of guys
Mannie fresh was as producer,
juvenile, little wheezy,
Lil Wayne, that whole crew,
they sold millions and
millions of records.
He has a net worth well over a hundred
million dollars cheaper. And you know,
he's just like the rest of the moguls
and hip hop. He has a fashion line,
he has liquor line,
he's very savvy,
very savvy business guy.
But in recent years he's gotten a lot of
flack for some of his record contracts.
The fact that he has little Wayne tied
up and won't let them out of a deal.
And so people have kind of
really shit on him for that,
especially within hip hop.
And so what's happening is
that this guy right here,
Charlemagne the God,
he had talked about bird man's business
practices with a couple other guests who
were hip hop artists,
trick daddy
and Rick Ross. I like Rick Ross
the boss. That's right. Chelsea.
Lately when I was there you and
you stole his hassle of that. Um,
well birdman comes in and
he has all this in his head.
Like you guys have been talking
shit. You will, you had Rick Ross,
me a trick daddy.
So he comes in right away and is like you
to put some fucking respect on my name.
I saw that. Yeah. Um, and then this
whole thing, this was supposed to be a,
an interview obviously last,
you know,
like less than two minutes. Oh, so he
didn't stick around and they didn't,
this is the whole thing. Now I already
got gave you a little bit of it.
So here's how it starts.
He said that before they were rolling and
then this guy is like, well let's roll.
Let's go, let's go. You know,
especially guests in the building.
You don't cross those out.
Tell them don't get it off your chest.
And I thought you were joking because
I don't want to stay in the angle.
Like what? So I come in, I did it
already. I'm hill. So was that,
I'm in, it's all good. But I'm saying why,
why, why and I'm here. What's happening?
I'm all good, but I'm saying,
yeah man, man, I want to see you.
I want to just talk to you. And
your man and your faith. Absolutely.
You understand me? I knew a few places
you wish that I could've pulled up,
but I don't think that was gangster.
I wanted to come look in your face like a
man and tell you how I feel. Okay? Yeah,
it's done.
Me Straight up like a man
and know you're filming.
I just come to let John know. Stop.
Put some respect on my name. No stemi.
When y'all saying my name, put
some respect on it. We spec.
Yeah.
Ari SBAC.
Kay Kay.
Put some respect on my name.
Pull up more roles that were trick daddy.
Now I'm pulling up on you Nigga. Oh,
I'm the radio guy.
Why wouldn't want to read it?
I've got all that stuff for the
radio guy. Me and my Nigga. Yo,
y'all are y'all finished?
I ain't got no talking.
Okay. Like 72 ago. It was nice chains.
You should get those [inaudible]
don't we all?
Are we all finished? Are Y'all done?
I ain't got no more talk. Yeah,
that's quite a question though,
right? What y'all finish? Y'All done?
You'll finish or y'all done or y'all done.
It's nonsense that he's given
them the same option. Sure.
Right. Are you finished
or are you all done? Yeah.
They need her waves and
know when. Yeah. Yeah.
I'd say don't pay the guy up that
has tattoos on reddit. Right.
You ready or you want to go, hey,
he's got a lot of tests. Yeah.
What'd you piss that guy off?
Teardrop stars.
He's got a fucking oil field tattooed
on the other side of his head. Really?
Oil coming out of, yeah. Boy.
Yeah. No. My question is though,
if you're just going to come in and
be angry, why go? Why go in at all?
I think for him that was him
making his point. His point was,
I am going to show up. Like he
misled them and said, ah, yeah,
I want to do an interview and talk,
but he really wanted to do was show
up and go put some respect on my name,
put some respect, don't talk
shit about me, you know? Wow,
that's a crazy move dude. Or You could
just say, I don't want to do your show,
but that's not, I mean then they don't
really understand how serious you are.
Yeah, I think on some level a lot of
people made a lot of jokes about this.
Like we've been making jokes about it too,
but on some level those guys in
that studio feel how serious he is.
I felt it. I got scared for a minute
there. I was like, Oh shit. Sure.
They're much more scared in the actual,
I don't know if it's in this
pre roll before they, um,
but when he comes in here and he's
like stop fucking doing this shit.
You can see the girl who's
part of the show and she,
her eyes darted around like was yeah,
cause he's bringing in all those dudes
like you don't know what's it going to
happen.
She knows that this is,
you can tell look like fights. She's, yes,
she's around some shit.
She's working the station long enough.
She's seen some fights.
Where the fuck is that?
God Damn it fucking sucks.
Pass Pi's mommy. No, I'll read user.
I want to start this shit
off straight telling Obria
so late in the day where they're all like,
Nah,
grand opening.
All right, well there
you have it. Are we good?
We good.
Let me go.
You know it's funny though as like all
the black people I follow on Instagram,
they're all lining up
this guy. Yeah, of course.
Posted some funny shit like some
remain buddy did clowning on it.
I mean I guess he's just had
he had his feelings hurt. Huh?
But he can't go in there and be
like, guys, my feelings are hurt. No,
no you can't.
Well he kind of said that.
I'm telling you how I'm feeling right now.
You know, just the respect on my name.
He said, he's telling me he's going to
pick on my name is Wes clever. My night.
He also took off and then put back
on his sunglasses like four times.
He's really upset.
Reminds me of PLP all day. All
right. We can hear her voice.
She's about to cry. He's been
inscribed. Yeah, put some
respect on my name. You can.
You can hear the quiver in the area or
a guy. Why he really got fired up? Huh?
He really did, man. Damn.
Poor guy. Poor Birdman.
Yeah. And then I like tennis.
I like to know his feelings or her like
that and I want to give him a hug. I bet.
I bet little Wayne had a
good laugh about that. Oh,
as Lil Wayne on his label or whatever.
I remember I just told you all about that.
Hmm.
I forget all the names you rattled off.
I mean, I heard finished. Are Y'all done?
Y'All finished? Is it, are you
shirts or all you all done?
Yeah. Yeah. Y'all finish.
Or is it often, is y'all done
finished? Are Y'all done?
He says or respect on my name.
SPEC on my name.
All of the day.
Respect their SPEC.
That's awesome. That is a good one. So
glad I brought that to your attention.
Go ahead. I missed you. You weren't
sperm can or how was it? Good.
It was really great. I had,
um, thankfully my buddy, uh,
the full charge of me and we had
really fun shows. The crowds were,
were excellent. It's a brand new club,
you know, it's only been open six weeks.
No Shit.
Yeah,
it's the same family that owns the Tacoma
Comedy Club to come on Ya to come on.
You also own sperm can cause they have
like the whole come locked down there
in Washington, but they
killed, they killed it.
They did a great job with the [inaudible].
Did you eat anything good? Yeah,
I went to uh, uh, Churchill's first night.
What's that chicken? It's a steak house.
Oh, Winston Churchill. Yeah, I've heard
of that guy. Not Churches. Chicken.
That's what I got churches,
Dude.
It's all show some respect on my name.
Churchill's um,
so yeah, I went there and then, yeah,
we had a couple of other, you know,
I DJ a little bit. I don't know if you
saw my Instagram, but a I hit up, uh,
I hit up a club and you know what I'm
saying? They was shut down already,
but they're like, we heard about your dad
mouth if you want to spend. I was like,
yeah,
I'll give you a little flare.
And then what you told me about
this and then you were like,
but what happened with it? What
do you mean? He like I showed up.
At what time did you start deejaying? It
was after they closed. So like two. Yeah.
And then you were like,
how many songs did you
not that many because I hit the weed.
Hmm.
Cause you're like, ah, I'm tired. But
that's because I hit the weed though.
And then Dj Dan mouth had to go.
So I had already had a drink or two
and then somebody was like, hey,
it's Washington smoke this. And it was
literally, I was with Matt and I go, Dude.
And then he does. And then I was like,
Ooh, I got to go back. And he's like,
I'm with you.
Whoo. Whoo. Whoo. Yeah, it was,
it was pretty quick.
Once you have the drinks in you.
Nah Man, that we both were
like, it's time to go.
I don't even think we said
bye to the people that brought
us there. We were like,
we're out. And we just kind of, I can't
even be high in public for that reason.
I can't talk to people when I'm
gone. You know, it's so funny.
I did a Jay Hawks podcast,
a football player,
and he was talking about how some wives
get resentful when their husbands are on
the road having fun. And I
was like, Oh yeah, I hate his
guts. Oh, you, you're the,
you're the like the wrote
the book on this. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm glad he didn't tell me you
were getting high and drinking.
It's not that I'd really hate your guts
a lot more. Saved it. Yeah. Yeah. Thanks.
Yeah. Now I hate you right when I'm
home with the kids trying to sleep,
train the babies, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's cool.
But I don't tell you that while it's
going on. So you don't want yes. Smart.
That's a smart move on your
part. Yeah, definitely. Sorry,
I'll get you back later.
Okay. What does this, does Luke
Wilson teach tennis? I like to learn,
but you keep mentioning Luke
Wilson. Oh yeah. I just like him.
Hey. Um, do you want to
tell them what happened? I,
before I left last week when we took
that a romantic dinner together.
So Tommy and I,
we've been together a million years
and there was one house I lived in.
My first shower was great. It was
like a fire, a fire hose dumping.
And it was a big shower. And you and I
used to shower together in the mornings.
Very romantic. It's going to be our work.
We had day jobs and we'd get up. Sure.
Yeah. 2005 genes and genes
showering together every
morning. It was really sweet.
I would put a shampoo on your head and
you had suds my bag and we make kissy
faces and then go to work.
Yeah. Now this next two houses,
we always had small shower so he
showers were out. Yup. Until now.
Yeah.
And we've got this wonderful shower
and a with two heads on it or whatever.
And it's really, it's a miracle. It's a
miracle. And so we know, we get the like,
hey,
let's go take a shower together.
It's been a good few years since we've
done that and it starts off okay.
And then all of a sudden,
um,
little things like you're
lathering your head but extra hard.
And then now the suds are
like hitting my eyes. You,
you like it freezing cold.
I like it warm like a person,
but you know like it warm.
You like burn third degree burns hot.
It's so hot. Yeah, that's a shower.
It's killing the bacteria. It's done.
And then my after,
so I'm like okay,
but I'll let that slide
don't say anything to you.
And then you spread your ass cheeks,
you spread them and you're not doing this
as a Joe spreading your ass hole open
and then the water's hitting your
ass hole and I'm right next to you.
Like really bro, you're going to do that.
All right, well it's a clean it out,
right?
Yeah.
You don't think you can be a little more
discreet or kind a bar soap and I put
it in there and then you go,
what are you doing? Yeah,
so cleaning my asshole.
But you're not supposed to take the
bar and mash it against the dirty part.
Yeah you are. No, that's what's savages
do. I've always done that. Yeah,
because you're a bear. You're not
a person. That's how you do it.
And that's how you do it.
But then you can Tammy. No,
you contaminate the ball.
Okay.
Oh that's what it was like.
Oh.
And then I made notes cause
I didn't want to forget.
And then you farted in the shower
cause you spread your asshole and
then you farted. And then my favorite,
unbelievable. This is, it gets wilder,
the hording, hording. Look,
he's next to me in the shower. I'm trying
to cuddle with you, kiss your face,
Kicks Your Beard,
You pee on me all the time in the shower.
You piss on me in the shower and all
that I can even tolerate until you blew
snot.
That was the deal breaker for me.
You were and then the snack came out
all over your beard and it gets stuck in
your beard and I almost vomited in the
shower. That's when I was like, all right,
I'm done. I got to go. I
almost threw out. I'm like,
it's like showering with a Hobo,
like a vagrant who's never been in an
indoor shower before. You were like,
it's a homeless person but you've
never been in a shower before I shower,
I forgot the horrors. Like you got
to clean all the pipes out, you know,
and got to get rid of all
of it. Apparently farted,
you spread your ass hole,
you hordes loogies snotting you pissed
on me. I didn't jerk off. That's the one,
the one boundary left in our marriage
or maybe we still haven't had that and I
have a white then on New Jersey and
I've been waiting for that to happen for
years.
I'm at the point now where I'm kind of
excited about sometimes now like it,
cause I used to be like really like Ooh,
be real careful.
But now I'm like just let it happen.
Let it happen.
Well I just expect it now. I'm like,
come on, she's going to walk in there.
What would you do? Finish and you'll just
look at me. Would you make eye contact?
Probably maintain it or what'd you
just get Outta here and then finish?
I think I would just be like, watch,
watch, watch, watch, watch, watch.
It's pretty long time since
what that we've been, you know,
together though that that hasn't
happened yet. It's kind of crazy.
Especially considering I do it pretty
often, you know? Yeah. When, when the,
when the baby's crying cause I
turned you on. You have a shower.
There's no bathroom door cause it's one
of those bedrooms where it just goes in
bathroom. Yeah. I know.
I've been waiting to catch you in there
when I've done it in the shower a few
times. So when I've been home. Yes.
Grote gross. That's probably when I'd
been with the kid though. Right? Yeah.
I hope you're smart enough to do it when
I'm with the baby as opposed to winter
when when I'm walking free
and maybe I'd come in and,
well why would I have to worry about that?
You're my wife.
I don't want to watch you jerking off.
I don't want to catch you and
have that horrible awkward moment.
I didn't know that.
Why would I want to catch you
masturbating? It's not part of my life.
I don't want to know it and I'll,
why don't to know.
I would think a lot of
people would want to see.
Nobody wants to see you masturbate.
Really? You look like a homeless person.
Do you know? You keep saying, Hey, blow
you blow your nose too, and as I jerk off,
art and whore can everything as I
jerk off. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Of course.
I have to get myself worked up.
I'm going to throw up.
Oh my God.
They tell you about the wife. I already
talked about this on the show about,
I'll talk about it again.
The wife that walked in on the husband
jerking off onto his shit. Yes. God.
Did you have to take it there?
Yeah. Julie, that one. Yes.
Some wild man. That's what I'm
afraid. Of course the come like,
I need to fucking know that. Okay,
listen, can I read this email? Yeah.
Subjects at double pipe. Classic
question. Very important. Very important.
Okay.
Hi Mommy's.
I was taking my regular dump this morning
when I let out the usual pre-brown.
Fuck you writes. I
burped at the same time.
I was absolutely shocked and
couldn't believe what happened.
It was a very exciting moment.
However,
does this count as an authentic pure
double pipe classic or would it be
considered a double pipe classic
with special circumstances?
Uh, I will point out that I
was sitting down on the toilet,
but the double pipe classic happened at
least 30 seconds before any brown exited
my anus.
Hmm. It's a really good question.
How do you feel about it?
You know, I think putting, um,
circumstances around a double pipe
classic isn't fair because look,
they're like Haley's comet, they
come around so rarely. Yeah.
It doesn't really matter how one has a
double pipe or just that one has a double
pipe.
Even
during a murder, if it's still a
double pack classic. No, like murder.
Yeah. Like if you were to be thrown out
of a building and as you hit the ground,
you fired in, birthed, you get
to take that to the credit. Yeah.
You get credit for that.
Yeah, I think so too. So, um,
I don't believe in the special
circumstance either. I would say, sir, you
devil biohazard over five classic and
it's, uh, it's something to be celebrated.
I would tell people about would make
Facebook posts. I would, yeah. Yeah.
That would share that. That's really
cool. Who invented that? That term?
Is that a top dog term? Mm.
Oh, it's generations old,
right? Yeah. Yeah. Has It in the
Bible? I think it's the old might be,
it might be in the Bible. It's certainly
in like Shakespeare and stuff. Yeah.
Oh definitely. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Dot.
Half made a double level five class.
I think it's in Romeo and Juliet actually.
Yeah.
Cause she kind of uh,
gets after him for having one or
something. Like she's on the balcony,
I remember that.
Oh Juliet.
And then he starts and burps
and she's like Romeo, what?
Double Pipe. Classic. Yeah,
that's right.
And that's what gets her,
and then they get married and then
you're here sitting here. Give me a, me,
me a hard time about it. But you know,
it's actually, it's, it's 11 lecture lab.
You know,
your sister just got married and I was
looking through those wedding photos this
morning and I was like, wow, look at what
a happy time. Just that wedding. Yeah.
Romantic. And then flash
forward nine, eight years. Yeah.
Taking a shower with your husband,
blowing snot rockets and spreading his
ass hole in the shower. It's pretty cool.
It is pretty cool.
I agree.
It's pretty little weddings.
A little misleading. No.
Yeah.
Are you saying you want me to dial it
back? No, there's nothing I can do.
Train's already left the station,
you know?
Hm.
Which is the one you want
me to cut out though. Oh Ma,
I the snot rockets that
rocket. Yeah. In the shower.
I don't even mind getting
pissed on anymore. Like I
just expect it now. I'm like,
Nah, what's that warm?
Um, it's Tom Peeing on me.
The ass spreading even that I
can tolerate. I think the horror,
the horror king and snot
rocketing. I can't, I can't,
I'm working a loogie is the way it makes
one of vomit. Oh, speaking of that,
um, this guy, big fan. Uh,
let's see if I can fake fan.
Yeah. He's a big fan of the show.
He's a big fan of what you
were just saying. Yeah.
Was it her or the other woman that was
offensive? Both were again, ballpark huts.
They had a smell,
they just smell that was displayed.
Discharge.
So this guy was trying to describe the
smell of a woman somewhere and he uh,
he keeps just gagging. He has a, a
dry heaving. Yeah. I don't like it.
Yeah, no way. You were
just describing it, so
I just can't
listen to drive.
No.
Why
farms smell?
He, he really, oh man. That's so
good. She's really tickled by that.
And she is, she is, uh, let's see if we
got this set up. Here. He is doing it.
Um, I can't watch dry
healing, uh, multiple times.
Oh my God. Well right.
Okay. I took it down.
He had the worst.
I got something else for you.
You're like this. No, come on.
That's bullshit.
I'm back. I'm bareback.
Dennis Rodman and back.
Wow.
Watch this bullshit.
Or our favorite family. Um, we are though,
is that our favorite family? That's
my bear valley. That's exactly right.
We have a clip of them.
Tony [inaudible]
teach you up.
Bam. Bell. You.
Ooh.
[inaudible]
here they are. Well, I'll just
have them. We have so much.
Oh,
I've seen this episode.
This lady was having orgasmic,
which, which, which nick,
for three hours,
she didn't voluntary.
It doesn't stop for several hours.
Even the woman, she was like,
I love them.
So
there's a twitch twitch or
something taking over your body.
So if a man has an erection
longer than he's supposed to,
direction goes, no baby.
That's that blue pill.
If you have an orgasm for three
hours and make you feel that good,
and if it, dude, keep it
away from me. I'm good,
Chad. That we're, yeah, that weird
affectation. That's Trina, right?
I'm the house.
She has that pronunciation that the
reason that it's so fucking bizarre, oops,
is that she grew up with them. Yeah.
She's the only one that talks like that.
They'll talk more. More. Trina
is who picks up the effect.
I don't really use the only weird part.
I mean if, if they all did that, ah,
this fleet,
where's the fee?
If he'll kill it feels so good at killing
flies and nobody's get a blue man.
Oh Shit.
It's about to go down.
Oh, close to working.
This is one.
Tamar was a little bit more normal there,
having their vagina steam that I remember
in this episode you have vaginas or
steamed. Yeah, they're, they're
getting their badge esteemed
right now. It's like so
weird. Yeah. It's on a stupid,
uh, but anyway, I think they
just did it for the show.
Like not real. Right? Like
a lot of things. Yeah.
Like we're going to get spray tanned.
They've got to end up giving those
people something to do, you know? Yeah.
They can't just sit around and talk.
They have to sit around and talk
and get their vaginas steamed silly.
Would you want to have a three
hour orgasmic Twix? Oh Wow.
Oh God.
We read your funeral.
Yeah.
And you just keep coming all
over him. All over. Your Dad
hold over your dad's dead body.
Gosh,
he doesn't come though every time,
right? Yes. Got stuff coming out.
But he's feeling like he's coming. Right.
But could you imagine anything in that?
If he just filled his pants all
the time too, then you'd have like,
his pants were all wet. That's right,
Babe. Can't pick up the kids at the,
you said that all or nothing,
you know, like you just
figured that out. I did that.
I didn't put that together more. Yeah.
Like his shorts would be all wet. Yeah.
You don't want to have nasty three
and four hour nasty directions either.
You know, you don't want that. No.
By Agra might be helpful. Yeah.
Be Bad. Yeah. Very bad.
Isn't that with Viagara does though? Yes,
exactly. A car for three hours. Yeah.
It's silly. Yeah. Can I
speak in of Dick hard? I got,
I'm a random text message by
Agra might be helpful. Yeah.
You know, this is the, the
new phone number, not even
new anymore. Maybe a year.
And I keep getting random
text and random voicemails.
I just got this one,
a Saturday,
10:35 PM and all it
says is sticks on deck.
Okay.
The fuck does that mean sticks on deck?
It sounds like I'm ready to fuck.
That's what I thought. Like maybe it's
a sexting thing. You're getting sex,
it sticks on deck. Maybe
it's a sticks on deck, bitch.
Maybe it's one of your comedy
club contacts. Yeah. Yeah, sure.
And then I, I texted my
millennial friends and she said,
it sounds like hold on. Sounds like can
you go to thousands? Like it sounds like
no, no, no. She goes, uh,
never heard that one. I'm going to stick
like blunt wraps. Maybe the blonde,
maybe the blends are on deck. Wow.
Your millennials. Very savvy. I know.
This is my one contact
with the young people,
the cloud deck six odd duck lunch or ready
for roll sticks on marijuana cigar if
you will. Yeah, yeah, sure. So fucking,
well not only did you get sticks on deck,
yeah.
You also got after
a long hiatus, new corrosion
voicemail. That's neat.
Right?
The same lady St Lady.
And it's weird cause it's been going
on for months and months and I have a
theory on this. I
understand. Okay. This lady,
like people that are from the millennial
generation that are from the generation,
even before us,
she perhaps is dialing from memory.
So she is dialing every time,
not doing a saves number.
I'm calling my friends and tiles and
is like a digit off every time or,
okay. That's one excellent
theory. Brown lock,
or she's got like maybe that the old
number saved in her phone and there's two
numbers for one person. You ever
have that in new one and an old one?
There could be. Yep.
That's another option.
The reason that I thought that she was
dialing from memory is that there are,
there's clearly,
there's probably some interaction in
between these things because he doesn't go
like you never called me back.
It means that they probably speak at
some point and maybe she's dialing
correctly, sometimes
incorrectly, incorrectly.
Other times she clearly hasn't figured
out that this number doesn't get a
response. So you're right. The
interaction kind of comes and goes,
which leads me to believe it could
be an alternate phone number.
Like with my dad, I have his old
number and is new, but then you, well,
here's what came in this weekend.
First.
Connie,
please airbnb to the chancery down.
You know enough nothing to do.
She shammy are now making notes on my,
it doesn't look any. Thank you so
much. Thank you so much. [inaudible]
that's really, yeah, Matt.
Okay, talk to you soon. Bye.
She likes so she throws it English.
Thank you Matt.
I was telling me to do, you can call me
[inaudible] airbnb to the chancery down.
You know how to do. She cheer me around.
[inaudible] it doesn't look me in.
Thank you so much Matt [inaudible]
office to talk to you soon.
Bye.
And then you think that's it and
then she calls you again. Again,
come on Rod.
But didn't you take the notice for the
comeback please rob?
So wait, it's Salamay I thought I'd solemn
and now this person's rob, this woman,
just dialing, dialing and
leaving messages for everybody.
No discretion now discretion. No
discretion to her dialing. Yeah.
Oh Man. That's the trick.
Styling together lady. Anyway,
I'm still getting those nice voicemails.
Yeah,
I suppose this is rob.
Come on, come on back.
I still get nursing gigs
for Shanaze synopsis.
This is Brad calling from them. The
newest Shit Nas would know. You know,
because she's
just missing out on all kinds
of business opportunities.
What are you doing?
No, I don't want it. She doesn't
vomit, but I don't like the dry heat.
That's when I'm like working.
I don't like it,
I'm closing it because you're
just torturing me. Torture you.
You're my wife.
So really sad news is
that we lost another icon.
Goddammit.
The day after last week's episode
aired on my flight up to a sperm.
Can I get a message?
Prince died. Oh my God,
it's devastating dude's we thought it
was because I dropped charges to the game
that my new football podcast and then
he listened to it and drop dead cause he
didn't like football. But that's not
what happened. It's not happened though.
First Whitney, then Michael, now prince.
That's the Holy Trinity.
I know.
There's only Madonna's the only
one left and she's the Holy Spirit
of the childhood stars.
Cindy Lopper I would say is another great.
He's 57. He was, he was
level. Yeah, I know.
We're going to get the autopsy
reports back. They sending
them to you? Well, yeah.
Well the guy, the coroner there said,
Tom, I'll try to get to you first. Um,
so that's like in another week or so.
I mean,
I'll probably get it tomorrow
for everybody, but, um, no,
I mean I'm curious as to see
what killed him. You know,
he's so that's too young to die.
Well,
they're saying it's quite that pneumonia
and then someone brought up a point
that he's a Jehovah's Witness and maybe
he refused medical treatment. Well,
he had an emergency plane landing the
week before he was flying back from a Gig.
Uh, they landed his plane in Illinois.
It was only like, I think it's Illinois,
right? It was only about 30
minutes or so from Minneapolis,
but they deemed it that important.
Landed, took him to a local hospital.
They wanted him to stay
in the hospital and he,
they didn't secure a private room
for him. Oh nope. It's Prince,
you should secure a private hospital.
So he took off the next day there
was a dance party at Paisley Park,
cause compound and oh wow.
Outside of Minneapolis.
And supposedly everything was fine.
And then obviously this is, you know,
then there was footage of him riding
his bike around his neighborhood and the
stopping in a record store. So all
that they said was fine. It does lead,
you know,
a lot of like the medical people to think
that you don't realize how many people
die of the flu and pneumonia every year.
It's thousands. That's for old people.
No it's not. It's not always got old and
young are more common than die with it.
But what the point being
that if your body is weak,
so he's already been hospitalized,
should have, say your,
your immune system is a little bit weaker.
You're already sick and then you get
that and you're not taking care of it.
You know, your, your lungs
fill up with fluid and you die.
Maybe HIV or something and nobody
knew. Who knows? We'll find out.
He so town he wrote songs for so
many people too, which is a crazy
part shit that you don't even know that
guy was responsible for. I just remember,
uh, purple rain came out. I bought
the album when I was a little girl.
Really seven or eight years old.
I had it on,
I had a 33 of when doves cry and on the
back was 17 days was another song and I
didn't know what that stuff,
I didn't know what masturbation was.
I learned about it from Darling Nikki.
I learned about sex through purple rain.
That was like one of the seminal,
if you will,
albums of my childhood and
Apollonia seeing her tits.
I remember she jumped in the lake,
Lake Titicaca or whatever.
I remember seeing Apollonius tents
for the first time. You're like, Whoa,
there's tits and a movie.
Prince was interesting. He
was kind of like, as a kid I
was like, what is this guy?
Cause he was so, you know, so
different but so singular, so unique.
Know I would watch see
prince and I was like,
this dude is unlike any dude
that I've seen or known.
Cause he had that kind of non binary
nonbinary quality to him.
Right.
He kind of morphed between the
two genders. He was a femme,
a femme at man, feminine, Heterosexual.
Like David Bowie.
David Bowie may have been bisexual.
There was rumors that he was sleeping
when era. Dude, he was, yeah. But yeah,
he was a fem guy and he was,
he loved it and he was short.
And you know what's so interesting about
friends and I have to tiny and he wore
those little heels is that prince was,
what was magic about him is
that he believed he was sexy.
He really believed that he was,
when you look at him objectively,
look at a picture, a photograph
of prints, and you'd be like,
this guy's fucking five feet tall.
He's a shrimp and he's tired.
But he exuded this
presence of like a sex God.
And everybody took him to be that
way, which is amazing. Crazy. Aw,
come on. That's a jam.
That's the jam. 1999.
Jim Purple Rain Is, I think a perfect
outcome. I still listen to it.
Um, the uh, I mean also, you know,
even even the early days, I was
staying a little later on, you know,
you get to some of the,
the songs that were just amazing
to listen to as well. And you know,
in honor of him, we have a little
bit of it. Cause we were, we were
big fans,
you know,
Shane,
late Tom and Christina
from your moms house,
podcasts
you need to teach.
You haven't seen diamonds
and pearls. I love girls.
Everyone loves this song. Yeah.
So good.
I liked his earlier stuff too.
Paisley Park and uh,
this, is this paused or no, no, that's,
that's just the intro to this. Oh,
you know that song?
Pay Sleep easy girl on know season.
That's a good song.
Yeah. Dude. He's got so many heads
dealer library it, it's, it's crazy.
Library. Yeah. The library yet.
Damn man.
Damn
such a good song. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Damn man.
Damn.
Okay. So we're just doing a little
sample. Well, you know, we get the,
they might flag it for
being a duplicate copy
of the audio matches up perfectly with
the original and then you do you want to
flag it? Breaks it down. So we
just gave you a low sample. Yeah.
You gave you diamonds amp
or it's not as diamond.
Yeah,
especially [inaudible].
I mean, Shane exuded everything
that I think Princeton in this, um,
even aesthetically similar, very
similar guys. It's a tribute.
It's really a tribute.
Um, obviously Shane, um, you know,
he wasn't doing his best there.
He makes that clear and a lot
of his clubs, he was like,
I'm not doing my best. Um,
you know,
it was interesting to point out
as I go through these pages here,
I'm looking for, I have more of
Shane, which I know you want to hear.
Everybody is on bated breath
waiting for more Shane Shane
episodes,
uh,
that we featured him
back to back a while ago.
Um, yeah, let me see.
I already had some technical
problems with that computer.
Um, perfectly, perfectly. Uh Huh.
Oh, that, I'll get that. I'll
get flagged for sure. Nice.
Yay.
Yeah, yeah, Yup. There you go.
But I really, I loved prince as a little
girl. I thought he was just amazed.
I still is, was, yeah. What a bummer. Um,
when we dedicated the
entire segments to Shane,
this is just trivia from our, your mom's
house turn is going to go on Wikipedia,
but this will go on the Wikipedia
page when we dedicated, um,
20 minutes to him on an episode,
I don't know, a year ago,
the following week,
our listenership went
down by over 30% easily.
And it took a while to regain
that. Yep. Nope, nope. Yep.
People were aggressively upset with the
emails. We got. Stop playing this guy.
He's the worst. He's the worst. So
yeah, we don't want to Overdo it with,
ah,
this was
a little bit half off
form or there is a feed.
Sounded like when he had a kennel cough,
it's exactly what he sounded like.
Um,
it's gone.
So rest in peace prints such a bomber
and you know, and then the shit suck.
Artists are still alive.
We know why not Justin Bieber take him
gun instead of taking the good ones,
you know? And there really isn't a climate
to nurture artists as weird as prince.
Now if you look at it, it's gone. You
get bloated. People like Patty Smith,
like these weird androgynous
people prance even Bowie,
right? These gender non
binary people if you will.
It's, it's gone. Gone is this
time? Well, you know, I, um,
a lot of people don't know this,
but I'm Polly and I buy and I'm also a
nonbinary come out as polyamorous and I'm
excited to share it that I'm bisexual.
I'm non binary to the non binary for
those of you don't know what the term
means. I'm surprised if you don't, I mean
who, who hasn't nonbinary these days,
right. President Obama went to
London and it was uh, taking,
taking questions from the audience and
a Pakistani person came out as nonbinary
to President Obama and that was on Twitter
and we were like, what's non-binary?
Yeah. It means neither gender.
Correct. It means you're,
you don't identify fully
with, yeah. Male or female.
I'm totally non-binary. Yeah.
Or you feel like that. Totally.
I'm like,
I'm Demi Demi gendered,
you know? Interesting. Yeah.
Interesting. I don't know.
I Dunno. There's so much, there's so
many different genders. There are a lot.
I'm going to see what my
dad thinks I'm going to,
if we can get them on the phone.
But I'll see that's the best part about
this stuff is asking our dads what they
think about these gender nude,
new gender norms.
I hope he answers.
So it was really
the first time
mom,
Bonnie, I've been doing recording
on the other line. Of course.
What I was trying to call the
debt and I here at your phone?
Yeah. Uh, yeah. I was calling from my
other phone. I have to a few phones here.
Ah, I felt to one city and I said it has
to be a salesman. I can by trying to me,
hey, I'm, I wanted to tell you
something I'm really excited about. Um,
I'm poly and I'm Bi and I'm non binary.
No,
what?
I'm Pauley and I'm Bi and I'm non binary.
Here's what I understand. I'm falling
and I'm by an unknown by knowing.
So I, I guess if I put it together,
he doesn't make any sense.
I'm polyamorous,
I'm bisexual and I'm non binary.
Yeah, you're bisexual. Yeah, but I'm also,
I don't do agenda then why don't you
become through a unit and you complete the
whole picture now? No, but
I'm not buying it can be seen.
It doesn't mean you're not wine.
I'm non binary.
Gender binaries. You again. Bye.
No, no. I don't identify as
either male or female. I'm just,
I don't, I don't identify
as either gender. So I,
whereby you cannot go to the bathroom.
They should be sure to
go by before the war.
Either one. I'm nervous. I'm nervous
unless we get Trump. Yeah.
Drums. The base a chance.
She's wanting to respect your
what? Nothing. Are you a Trump fan?
I am. Nobody. Nobody. I mean, this
is awful. This is embarrassing.
Yeah, absolutely. The idea,
but I'm gonna Watch you.
They talking isn't most fake
teaching after everything. Hi,
miss my London is a typical politician
is telling you everything you want them
to hear the way you want to be.
I don't feel [inaudible] so that
time it's a not great six boy,
but I think I have to do
husband run the country.
I will love to see a worksheet
then. Casick yeah. Yeah.
Is the only guide from
Eaton on it's completely
knowledgeable and [inaudible] is
mark. I neither. Yeah. Cool.
Do you like when I do you want Hillary?
Um, I want, I just,
I'd rather have just another non binary
person leaving the country, you know.
Well why don't you run?
Well that's the thing. Um,
that's the other announcement I wanted
to tell you that I'm probably going to
run for president.
Mom is not a joke. Okay. I take it though.
[inaudible] oh,
oh Christina or anything
this important for the apart.
Christina wanted to tell you
wanted me to while she's here,
but she wanted to tell you about the
shower we took the other day. Um,
cause she's been like,
I'm going to tell your mother because
we took a shower together here at tell.
Tell her baby
can she hear me? Yeah. Hi.
Yeah, I can hear. Yeah.
So your son and I, yeah. You're
going to love this, your son.
And I thought it would be romantic
and loving to take a shower together.
Okay. I can almost, I can almost guess
what she did. What do you think happened?
I think he started falling and
close. No, right.
He spread his butt cheeks
to get the water on it.
He used the bar of soap and he
put the bar in his butt hole.
I'd have to take it.
Yeah.
Tell me the stories he told.
Don't somebody telling me
is both because I think,
I think my husband will
enjoy it and be proud of him.
Wait, it gets better and then gimme
it gets worse. You know it can go.
It gets worse.
So then he starts Horkey
Tyler like hawking a loogie.
Okay.
Ah God.
Oh
No.
And then he blows,
not he,
he puts one finger on one nostril
and pushes the snot out of the,
do you think that's enough? I can.
I can even do that maybe if I can.
Yeah. And then this one, I
love to hear it anymore. No,
I'm promise you. And then the smell
wasn't his beard and then he peed.
He peed on me in the shot.
I can imagine any relevant with
that imagination. Nevertheless,
she did something horrible thing for
like 70 years of life I ever heard.
And you think this is Tony?
I don't think it's funny. I think it's
horrible. I think we were trying to have,
I wasn't
think well that for driving me.
He just told me that he's not by me,
but he's nothing.
He's Bi sexual but doesn't qualify.
And you don't mind that
he's bisexual by the way.
Oh, I see. Yeah, he's, well,
he's Paulie. He's polyamorous,
bisexual buddies, non-binary. So
he's not attracted to either sex.
Oh, I thought you, I was
like tension. So he's,
he's wanting kids by fit you to,
right.
But he's also nonbinding
cancers that both sexes,
but I'm neither sex. Right.
He's asexual. It's very,
very hurtful that Christina did
well after we took that shower,
she told me that I, that I
was a homeless person. That I,
that it was like showering with a
homeless person. Isn't that rude?
We didn't come this Thursday.
Yeah.
She said that showering with me is like
showering with a homeless person because
I'm sweating.
Why I do if you have not been great
in the homeless people and why? Why?
I don't know what you mean.
Ask her about,
they call me first time we screened them.
She's taking the cello.
So what is wrong?
Ask her about the comfort or if she
noticed that he was washing the comfort
those right. That's true.
That's a good point, mom.
Hey Dad told me the other day that he
farted on the bed and that there was shit
on the bedspread.
It did its job.
And what did you think
when you heard this?
I walk in the house and I see
you in the washing machine has,
I guess,
should we say that?
But I guess what you said what it was.
It wasn't naturally I didn't,
but I,
I had to meet them farm and again it
was one of the for the noise. Yes.
Modified for,
yeah.
Do you know that those aren't mine?
Do you know that those are called a shore?
Do you know those are called the shark.
I have. Knowing that. Interesting.
Knowing the name of God because if I
have one of those, I have been doubt.
I go to the bathroom.
No, no. It's called a shark.
It's called a sharp sharp s. H. A. R. T.
It's sharp.
Oj can be sharp thing.
Right? Because when you go to the
forest but you shit, so it's a sharp,
well, usually you have one
or both is and I'm like,
it's [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] pounds under the
bed. Then you pooping a bunch of them.
That's a good point actually.
That's a good point. Yeah.
Having to go through so much. It's that.
Now, do you that distinction, did you,
it's a very important distinction.
Did it bother you that he didn't remove
the poop stains from the bedspread?
He just put with the chunks
of poop into the Washer.
All right.
Would you mind to change the topic of
conversation because it's so disgusting,
but I know I was in good
call. I was having a cup of
coffee with the coffee cake.
Yeah.
I never scoring the set for my dog.
I hung up with the bed to say who is this
person was calling me to both numbers.
It has to be somebody
important by parents.
I so somebody who wants to go first
today it goes damn that inconvenient.
Inconvenient. They call you and
your the one to tell you bullshit.
I knew before I buy it.
Right.
But it tends to be you to talk about
poop which is getting worse or or we're
talking but we're worried about you.
I'm worried about and even then you
haven't even been, how is the baby?
We don't own my baby. He's in the
cray right now. He's in his, yes,
he's locked up.
Yeah.
Give it to me because you're so busy
now and but [inaudible] [inaudible]
no I'm poly and I'm Bi but
I'm also nine button nonbinary
yeah and buy and buy and non binaries.
I'm going by noon.
Nonbinary long by name
and what is non binary?
I don't identify as either gender.
That's pretty sad.
If you know him mind.
Here's the thing, when you referred to
me, you don't say he like you don't go.
He would like to do that. You say
they, so if somebody says, okay,
right, right. Yeah,
so I say you had nothing actually you
don't know the date when you clarify this
again. You guys are okay.
They are not in vain.
It nothing.
I'll do it.
My point is don't identify like this
and you don't mind if you buy like that.
That's a little but okay. Through
my kitchen. Say what I'm doing.
Neither one. Nothing. Well, I don't
know if I'm a your kitchen table.
I'm telling you I
and you have no feeling.
You're not attracted to either one.
You are not by sexual.
We are not boarding are not
[inaudible] you. I guess
that's not the day. You are not two
people. The opposite. Losing yourself.
We prefer they what? I'm sorry.
Tell her they are not the people in there.
Tell her we're making yeah name
and you're not. You want to be both
and she doesn't mind and do it. Oh God.
Chara we're making sure to raise Ellison
and non-gender conformist environment
too. We're going to dress him
up and paint that right now.
You just told me they're joking.
What do you mean what? No,
I don't want him to grow
up confused. Yeah. Okay.
Can I pick up the baby?
And I said, good guys.
They can make up a lot of years and we
didn't buy well when he's done playing
with those dolls. Yeah,
maybe. I'm sorry I seen him.
I think she deserves to be
in the normal environment.
I would carry what she is and what God,
maybe we have a different
definition of normal. Yeah.
But I that I know what's on
my list because I'm only 8
million years old living.
Do I know Norman? Okay.
Whatever. All right.
Changing the topic of direct
conversation by the way. Yeah. Yeah.
We went to the movies yesterday.
I don't even know if the movie recruiting.
I do a lot of it. What is it?
What? My name is [inaudible].
My name is Dolly or Paul
[inaudible] name is Dolly and Pie.
My name is Paul by, no, my name is Doris.
Doris. Doris. Okay. I know what's what,
what is it about? Yeah. What's it about?
Uh, when did you have on the woman?
Yeah.
Younger guy. And once you go through
and I mean he hit add thing is super.
I mean, they don't give false gods
for the title, but you will be for it.
Well, that's cool. All right.
[inaudible] yeah,
no,
it's a movie that it's a good thing
he made you laugh in different. Good,
cool. We'll check it out when they
make a poly by version, but mom,
can I call you back on the other line?
I went to talking about a bitch. Yeah,
no, no. We'll talk baby stuff and
everything. I got to go take a shit.
I'll call you when I'm done with this.
I don't think they teach it because he
never chewed him up in the bathroom. Yeah,
I know. Excuse me. Excuse me. No heat.
No heat. They should the [inaudible].
There you go. Hey. Yeah, you're
getting there. I'm finally.
Yep. All right you.
Bye. Bye. Love you. Bye.
You know we should do when they come
visit next week then it's dangerous,
but I'll take your neck,
brother and my mom.
We should buy dolls for Ellis
when she comes over next time.
[inaudible] like barbies
and put them around. Ellis.
It's true and put them in address.
See if they like it. Yeah,
it's a good idea. Yeah. Well that
wasn't well, that was great. Yeah.
She's not as supportive as I was
hoping for, but you know. Nah,
I hate when people aren't as supportive
as they should be. This stuff, you know,
I know progress.
People are trying to make
Pauley and I'm buy it.
Let's get some progress.
Um, yeah. Here's the time. I told my
dad, hey, you got to tell you something.
I'm Pauley and I'm bi.
I'm poly and a buy.
How was the best day of my life when we
told me dad, you were going. He goes,
all right buddy. Well ACDC,
Huh? Oh, switch hitter.
Right. That's so funny. I love explaining
this stuff to the older generation.
It's really fun. I can't wait to tell my
dad about non binary. I don't, I dunno.
They make their heads explode when
you try to explain this stuff to that.
I was talking about the bathroom thing.
If North Carolina with my dad and he
was like, we've stumbled, he has a dick,
then they can piece next to me.
But if they don't have a dick,
they can't come into the bathroom with
me. I'm like, that makes sense. He's like,
I don't know why people aren't worried
about children pissing next two grown men.
That's more worrisome.
I mean you actually have a point
like what's he worried about?
Like you know how in men's bathroom
stalls guys just fucking pee next to each
other and if you're lucky there's some
kind of a divider and sometimes there's
not. Yeah. He's like, I think we should
be more concerned about like little boys.
That is the bigger issue.
You don't know what the,
what the grown men are doing. It's
terrifying because you're a little kid,
a little boy.
Public restrooms are kind of terrifying.
I mean the fact that you
should be expected to whip
your genitals out in front
of strangers is really crazy.
People piss on the floor and like,
oh yeah. There's just like, it
is intimidating to be, you know,
as you're the height of the
other people's dicks. Oh Geez.
I mean your face is that their
cognitive level? Yeah. Pull out.
You got to go with Ellis whenever you're
out with him, make sure that, okay,
thanks. Don't just let them go
alone. Pissing everywhere. You know,
I'm just thinking about the
future right now. Of course,
my terrified sign of these monster Cox
all over him, all over him, you know,
and around him I kissed him on the
head with it and stuff. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. It's a bigger, it is a bigger issue.
Let's keep our son's protected
from these monster public dicks.
It's really the jumbo as he liked to call
yours. Jumbos he's something else, man.
He is something else. That was really
funny. Your mom really didn't like the,
the shower that we took together.
Got To really know.
What I noticed is that she will
talk longer about gross things.
She doesn't like if it's coming from me.
Right.
Like we get a little longer of a rope.
Yup. But when it's just you, she like,
we'll hang up on you. Yeah. So in the
future, this is a great tag team. Sure.
Give it to me. Let me tell her
the details. Yeah. Cause she'll,
she'll stay on the line longer.
Yup. Uh, and for those of
you watching on Youtube? Um,
the reason that I handed the laptop
over is because we were using,
you hear us through the
recorded microphone,
but she hears us through the
microphone in the laptop.
So if you're wondering like why the fuck
are they doing that? It's that, oh yeah.
I didn't feel like at a certain point
in that call though, she was like,
y'all are y'all finished? Are
Y'all done? You know, some respect.
Yeah, she was definitely like put
some respect on my name. Awesome.
By all of those.
Well hold on a day.
It was definitely what was going on
Ma. I love you. Bye. I love you. Yeah,
she was definitely,
I know you guys are dying to know
what's up with Betsy and her diarrhea.
[inaudible] took her to the vet and they
tested her poopies to see if there's
some kind of viral whatever.
And it's not that she is just stupid and
she's eating stuff in the backyard and
they basically said that yeah,
the vet was like, you know what?
Some dogs are dumb and
just eat everything.
So you have had to get a special dog food
to offset the fact that she will just
eat horrible things and give herself Dyer.
Ooh. Ooh, Mama. I love you
mama alone practically in tears.
My name here.
You got two of them together. You all
are we all finished? Are Y'all done?
Yeah, it's great. Yeah.
Um, linkedin is helpful.
Linkedin is helpful.
Fuck. Lincoln Lincoln,
Lincoln Den. Um, also I,
uh, I watched a Hitler movie. Oh,
on Netflix called look who's back.
It's a German film and it was
actually pretty good. Really? Yeah.
It took a neat twist.
I didn't think it would go
where it's interesting. Yeah.
They made a movie that Hitler wakes up
in the year 2015 or 2014 I forget. Yeah.
What's it called? Look who's back. Look
who's back. It's in German. It's subtitle.
It's so fun. I loved it. It was
really funny. And you love it.
The m really interesting social
commentary and all that crap. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, do we have a couple of other things?
Oh, first we made this announcement.
I should probably get to a that
we haven't gotten to yet or no,
your mom.
It's
news.
Um,
so at summit or something I wanted to
make sure we had our ducks in a row for,
for awhile.
Um,
and so I was talking to blue band and
had to make sure everything was lined up
and then uh,
he flew
a couple of places for me and
made sure we were set to go.
Um,
and he did this for me and that is that
we are now ready to bring out the new,
the all new bikes shirt.
Oh my God.
Oh my gosh.
This is something that um,
was originally on our uh,
on our mommy jams on this show.
And then I,
I made a bit about it on um,
on the uh, Netflix special. Yes.
And then now it is ready to go.
We have a bunch of them.
They are absolutely fire.
We even have a bye
bye.
Bye Bye.
Yeah, that is great. A blue band did a
good job. Blue Ban. That's really neat.
Really good work.
Ban Harris is that,
is that promo up anywhere
that people can see it?
It's going to be just showing
it here for the first time.
That's a really neat design.
Elisa. Yes, the new bike shirt.
And we had one for a while.
This one is on a much
higher quality tee shirt.
It's an all new design.
It has a few bikes on it and of course
it has the word bikes in big black
letters. Um, the store is now up. Uh,
if you go to Tom cigarette.com, uh,
and your mom's house, podcast.com,
you can check it out and uh, we're very
excited and we have them fully stocked.
So there is, it's not a
presale, there won't be the, um,
the issue that we had before with a lot
of you waiting on your sub cane shirts.
I profusely apologize for that and uh,
it won't happen with these.
And the sub cane shirts that you do see
on my site are only ones that we have in
stock.
So we have a new system that counts the
inventory and eliminates shirts that are
no longer there. You will not have to
wait again. So a thousand apologies.
Please get the bikes shirt.
It supports us.
It supports the show and
it supports, um, you know,
it supports our, our guy here,
our uh, our producer blue man,
mother fucker. Yo. So
please get them cheese.
It's really, um, anyways,
I'm really about by extreme
good. That's exciting guys.
Yeah. Pick up your shirts.
Do your shopping on Amazon,
get on Linkedin, then his help
fall. Uh, is there anything else? Mm,
I don't think so. I think we
covered a lot of topics. Yeah.
Take detectives. Yeah.
Do you want to do that?
The Donald Trump Dick
detectives real quick. Okay.
Okay. Um, sure. One second.
Let me pull this up.
Yeah ma'am.
Yeah.
You have a, um, a number of where these
jpegs are supposed to bring up. Yes.
Okay. Um, so here is a
image of him and to get you get your
mind in the right place. How about Shara?
With,
there's political commentary.
He's such a terrific picture. Looks.
It does look like he just finished.
She's like, ah, I guess. Feels good.
Feels good that you just put
a finger on it. Feels good.
You have a finger in the
booty hole right there.
Isn't that kind of looked like a pleasure
face. Yeah. Um, yeah, there's Turkey back.
So you want to go first?
I mean everybody knows the answer to this.
I feel like it's kind of a no brainer.
Yeah, it's obviously orange. It's orange,
orange with fluffy white.
Pubes.
What about size wise? There's been
a lot of talk about his hand size.
He was accused of having small hands and
then he made a very clear message that
my hands, first of all, he
doesn't think they're that small.
And also no one's ever complained about
my manhood. So he was basically saying,
I at least don't have a small Dick.
He didn't say, I have a big Dick,
but he didn't say I have, you know,
he said no one's ever complained.
I'm going to go for short
and thick like a coke can.
But it's short. It's not, oh, can,
but it's thick cocaine is. Yeah,
but it's not, it's not great because
it's too short. How short or is it,
I don't know. You know, I don't
know. It's a short, short,
it's orange.
Hmm.
Well the white cubes
and his beans are tiny.
I think he's got small little.
Okay. What do you think?
I think it's actually like a little,
like a cute little button. Like,
um, there's actually, I
saw, yeah, this is it here.
There's this sketch that um,
that I've,
that I saw of that. Uh, what's her name?
Elma. Is that her name or did it Elma.
Gore. Yeah. Elma Gore did
a sketch of him. Let's see.
And um, I'll try to print,
bring it up here. It's, it's,
it's become very popular and I
think in my mind it's very accurate.
Um,
as far as here it is here.
Oh yeah. Right. Yeah. Uh
Huh. Yeah, this totally,
that makes sense.
When you look at the in proportion to
the body type where it's like the real
small placid. Yeah. He's got a nice,
cause he's got some weight on him and
he's got a nice fat pad here and a,
and it basically you just see the head
kind of poking out when it's flacid and
then it probably grows I think probably
around four inches, you know? Yeah.
I don't, I don't think he's got anything
extraordinary going on down there. Yeah.
Yeah. Uh, I would give him a little
more length on that. You think so? Yeah.
But the shape of it and the color and
everything looks about accurate, I think.
Uh, yeah, I think that's about it. I'm
going to go with illness. Uh, depression.
Wow. I think it's really accurate
and you know, I'm not going to lie.
It looks a lot like
mine. Um, so that's, uh,
it's kind of what I've been
saying and I don't think so.
He doesn't have any balls in that picture.
I definitely have all their tiny,
has walls are tiny. I
definitely a balls. Yeah.
Bigger balls longer hanging here.
Guns, how full they are. Yeah,
they get full sometimes. It's
like your dad's, they're bigger.
So gross. Um, so, but the,
the problem with this episode
of Dick Detectives is a,
we don't get to ask Donald,
so which is it?
Cause that's how we usually like to play.
I mean blue band.
Do you want to decide
who is more accurate?
Is it a coke can and girth and
short or is it what I saw there,
that little head,
the Elma drew and about four inches long.
A Blue Band just gave me
the point and the thumbs up,
meaning I win this
round. Wow. Of dicta tech
did.
Yeah. What kind of Dick, I mean,
what would be your ideal
Dick to have ideal,
not one of these fantasy
digs that you see, you know,
in sex stores or on a few porn
stars that are chest Garcon.
I think that's too crazy.
I think everybody would want,
the ideal one would be like a little
above average in everything go longer than
average low girth here than
average. Um, so I don't know,
maybe like eight. It's like long, but
not like what the fuck is that right?
So eight inches long.
And then maybe like where your finger,
like your fingers don't quite touch
when you hold it. You know, like mine,
I can go like this and
like I'm looking type,
put fingers around it like
four times. And then, you know,
if somebody were to like walking on me
I could just put like three fingers down
and cover it.
You know,
what color would be an ideal penis color?
I think like a deep purple would
probably be the ideal color you see it
sometimes depending your blood situation.
But I think if it was like just deep,
deep purple from from base to head all
the time, that'd be an ideal color.
What, how does that happen? Is
that one, it's just follow blood
I think. Yeah. I mean, and then what's
going on with your veins and yeah. Yeah.
And then what about balls? Balls? I mean,
ideally you want probably pound
and a half, two pounds each.
Um, you know, cause nice, big
balls are exciting to women.
And what about hair? Oh, heroin. So
of course, careless naturally. Yeah,
I'm sure even that thing up all the time.
And I know it's such a hassle to shave
pubic hair. I hate it. I'm so over it.
I really wouldn't, I wouldn't mind
removing it all. Yeah, I know. Me Too.
That'll be kind of neat.
Yeah.
Huh. Interesting. Why don't you guys
come at you? What's your ideal one?
Yours is my ideal. Where we go.
That's the loving answer course.
Of course. Of course. No, no, yours
is perfect. I really don't. I think,
oh my God, it's not an
objective thing. It's the person
this made me laugh so hard is
the, yeah, it's here. So, um,
we had this, you know, with the
last few weeks we played the,
the woman lifting weights and screaming.
Yeah.
And then we had the woman
getting the Tattoo and
screaming. Yeah. And now we have,
um,
armrest,
these,
an armrest sometimes
guys laughing.
Wow. Dude, I can't even
wrap it. You hear him?
He was like, Hey, you're
a rapper. She's so weird.
Put your hands here.
Wow. What a weird Baird. Yeah.
Do you think she does that to psych out
the opponent or, I'm sure it's natural.
It's her thing, you know? Yeah, it works
okay.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. It definitely works.
So,
so good. That's the thing I'm looking
for. Labeled everything again.
Another one called everything.
Okay. So this is a man.
This made me so happy. Um,
blue band put together.
Wait, is this it? This is it.
I hope so.
[inaudible]
what? Masterful work. So
good to arm wrestlers,
the weight lifter and lady getting the
Tattoo screaming all at the same time.
It's good shit.
Yeah.
Which one's your favorite? Um,
ah, it's so hard. This is Libby.
I hate and love at the same
thing. The taxi waiting. Uh,
she's like, yeah, I know. Allen's
great. Her face is so ridiculous.
I liked the old lady in the corner. Yeah,
the weightlifting. Now it's all good, man.
You can't, you can't really go
wrong with this one. Um, look,
there's other stuff we didn't get to,
but I think we've got to wrap up the show,
man. Yeah, there's uh, too much. Uh, okay.
Thanks for watching. If you're
watching and if you're not watching,
why aren't you watching us on Youtube?
Silly genes, but it gets your life,
your life.
There's two closing songs.
Yeah.
Pick the one that says farting. Okay.
That's how you know it's good. All right,
well that's our show. Got It.
Um, please. Your mom's house,
podcast.com Tom Cigarette Dotcom.
Please get the bikes shirt.
It's on sale. Um, we
have, this store is being,
has a few other shirts
and it's being rebuilt,
so please support the show and that's
it. Um, domestic shipping history,
by the way, so. Oh, that's
nice. Nice. Anything else,
James? You're good. That's it.
I love you. I love you.
Bye Bye farts. Hi Mommy.
Very good man.
Like he'll put his leg up
like a diaper placement,
placement
placement.
Like he'll put his leg
There's no,
Oh
yeah,
yeah.
Like he'll put his leg up
like a diaper placement,
placement
placement.
He'll put his leg up like a
diaper placement placement.